[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to the show we have a new face not a new
face she's been here before she's been
here before uh but she's back she's back
with us today uh
how we feeling everybody Howie before I
get into introducing everyone how are we
feeling on this fine Thursday afternoon
feeling good yeah well because the Vibes
are feeling good the Vibes are mixed in
the chat Greg so you know makes makes
Vibes already yeah dude darian85 asked
if uh we could trade the uh the producer
rat Ryan for live mood so Liv congrats
you're you're in a trade proposal but my
ass is in the jackpot so yeah that's
crazy the chat is comfortable like that
that's crazy they're too the chat's too
comfortable the chat's too yeah it
sounds like it
a
Ryan I'll just be transparent
I'll take that trade but uh uh
introduce everybody that's here my name
is Greg Ivory uh y'all know who I am my
name is Greg Ivy next to me is the
lovely live moods and next to her is
well you know you guys call him a rat we
call him producer Ryan some some also
say the man of the people don't forget
that whoa whoa whoa all right live live
I I gotta ask you I gotta ask you
Ryan's trying to self-proclaim himself
amen of the people do you think that's
the way to go do you think it's like the
self-proclamation thing or do you think
like the people should decide then not a
self-proclamation well I don't think you
should have opened the show by reading
that comment if you were gonna say
you're a man of the people I think we're
doing a little bit of contradicting here
but I you know listen usually they're
toughest on the people that they love
the most it's all love at the end of the
day so you might be on to something
that's a good point yep these are the
Vibes I needed yep it is all love at the
end of the day uh well we're back we're
back here to build another parlay live
just want to keep you transparent and
everybody at home Ryan ruined the parlay
last week once again so it's time to
cook up
another one like DJ Kelly said drop your
Best Bets for tonight's TNT games into
the chat we talking Knicks Celtics
Maverick Sons Ryan
what are they talking about in the chat
I want to I want to talk about what
you're talking about how the hell did I
ruin the parlay last week you dropped
Dante divincenzo he sold no no no no no
no you you ruined the parlay Ryan what
The Vibes starting the show you know
it's all about the Vibes Ryan The Vibes
wasn't there the Vibes wasn't there bro
okay you just just own it no so no this
is just how we open the show every week
it's producer Ryan ruined the parlay but
I don't actually know how producer Ryan
ruined the parlay it's I it's I'm
confused every single time we just leave
it in the script every week because we
know
it tends to happen a lot so uh
okay what do the people saying right are
they what are they saying that you
ruined the parlay last week or are they
giving us locks uh they're asking me if
I'm hungry for a burger and they like my
uh they like my cowboy hat
um what's up gay yeah so gang war said
uh Julius Randle under 27 points Dante
kashaw said Jalen Brown 20 plus points
uh we're seeing I'm seeing DeMar DeRozan
takes the Bulls aren't on TNT tonight
people let's let's get it together uh
look at Darren 85 Greg did make that
call yeah then make that call Darian
knows Darion knows darion's no snake uh
bowling said Spencer did witty 15 plus
points
oh I missed playing man do we do we give
him some love here what do you think
what do you think Liz let's consider it
yeah that's that's the first one that's
caught my attention in a good way so
let's hang on to that one
yeah yeah let's see what let's see what
it do didn't witty to get 15 that should
be a layup right his total is at 18 and
a half so 15 plus minus 350. that's a
good first leg if we're doing five legs
here I'll take it minus 350. yeah I'll
take it I like that I think that hits
easy uh should we ask the child or
should we just move on uh well and you
know and then we've got Mike Ritter
jumping in here and saying next money
line and just dancing on My Grave we're
not doing the Knicks are eight and a
half Point underdogs can we agree that
we're not taking next next money line
yeah we're good we're good I'm good yeah
we can stay off of that one okay all
right thank you Liv you seemed a little
okay all right I'm just trying to make
sure that you stay I want to keep your
head on straight like you're on the edge
here so we're gonna keep the Knicks out
of there okay
um
let's see uh Dante Castro is back RJ
Barrett 15 plus points uh bat bath Ave
boy he told me how to say it one time
but it's spelled like batave boy uh he
said yeah he's very particular about his
username and how it's set it gets me
every time yeah bro like how about this
maybe just pick an easier username to
say like I don't know it's pretty pretty
simple uh but he said Al Horford over
one and a half threes is a lock and
dropped five lock emojis
oh oh that's a lot of lock emojis yeah
that's a lot that kind of gives Good
Vibes I I would agree with that should
we go over and check it out let's check
it out yeah let's take a look
Al Horford he was knocking down some
threes
against my team not too long ago
minus 132
should we do the thing and tease it down
or do we think it's gonna be let's let's
just take it let's take a look
minus eight minus eight fifty Jesus
minus 229 I'm going to say we probably
have to take the regular the regular
line
um
all right we're I'm gonna ask the chat
I'm gonna ask the chat how they feel
thumbs up or thumbs down
yeah or we could put a pin in it but
yeah thumbs up thumbs down live do you
have a lean on this
I love Al
I love betting on Al I mean mostly
playoff out and we're not there yet but
I like I like over one and a half I do
this is this is prime time out though
he shows up yeah it's kind of like
playoff out yeah that's what I'm saying
TNT you got out on TNT
he knows what he's doing
yeah I dig it put it in thumbs up thumbs
down I see a thumbs up already I see one
thumbs down I see two thumbs up in the
comments uh
when you see Darian when you see Darian
85 given a thumbs up you know you've
done something right the man loves
thumbs down
oh here comes some thumbs Downs coming a
few more thumbs up
um that's 50 50. mm-hmm
should we just rival live
you're the tiebreaker
I well I I do have a play it has nothing
to do with Al so if you need another leg
I've got one
TNT prime time I think he's got it okay
all right before before we lock in I'm
we're gonna lock in I just got to be the
numbers guy I'm gonna go look it up
BC what he's been doing B Thompson 1992
says no threes bro locked Tatum 30 piece
why don't we just do both it's a five
leg parlay why do we have to hate on one
leg where we just add it
right it is a five-legged parlay but
Ryan to answer my question
he said over two and one two three four
of his last five games so
it's headache and we're giving him a
prime time spot
it's money yeah I think we're gonna do
it yeah it's money this is uh don't
think just throw
uh
all right Jason Tatum's at 30 and a half
what do we want to do here
I did look at him
I did look at him to have himself a
knight and what did you find
I liked it yeah I mean how do you but
how do you resist Tatum right now with
the numbers he's putting like it just
feels it feels shameful to not bet on
him right now but yeah I mean I like it
personally Jason Tatum over 30 and a
half
he has been balling he has been bowling
also he's been rebounding kind of well
he's been sneakily rebounding very well
might be a sneaky one I don't know just
saying I don't know he had 19 rebounds
the other night I don't know if I'd say
I know he did yeah
Mr Mr Man of the people
somebody's rsj said this is the coolest
and most quiet I've ever seen my boy
Greg
whoa
relax relax
uh the other Ryan the other thing is you
you're a man of the people I've been
seeing Julius uh
I've been seeing Julius Randle rebounds
quite frequently in the comments and if
you were a man of the people you would
address that but you know I know it just
doesn't fit my agenda that's all
yeah
I'm glad we're hearing the truth
hold on I'm honest about this every week
I walk in here if the Celtics are on TNT
I have an agenda I do everything I can
to protect it and I push all the next
propaganda to the side
knowing that Ryan has an agenda and he's
trying to push his agenda on our parlay
the people in the chat now uh do we want
to do like
I mean we could do we could do Randle
rebounds what's it at it's at 11 and a
half
two we gotta at least address it the
people like there's more than
I also just like Rob Williams is not
like the rebounding guy or the
rebounding God that we think he is like
the I don't know I I kind of like it Liv
I I lean more towards you and on how you
feel about this
I think I think if you were true man of
the people you'd uh you'd ride with the
with the chat I think we gotta take
Julius Randle okay come on all right wow
hey
hey yeah I've been trying to tell you
bro I don't know man of the people carry
themselves a certain way yeah the way
you've been doing it
you know
I don't know if that's the way Greg I
don't even know if you heard him but
when you said man of the people he goes
thee
so he's like empathizing it like he's
doubling down so we gotta put Randall in
there we have to we got to now the
question is should we tease it down or
should we keep it where it's at now
you're speaking my language
here we go what
what if we find common ground you Ryan
you're not loving it a hundred percent
so what if we tease it down we stick it
in there but we tease it down four plus
rebounds
four I mean
you are you're wrong for that one
four plus
uh yeah what's what is it at four I bet
you they don't even let us bet it at
four plus yeah look it's just no uh
um all right if we were to do eight it'd
be minus a thousand and what would that
what would that do for us pretty much
nothing it would be plus 145. and then
10 plus gets us to
I don't know
only 190. that's what I'm saying so if
it does if neither one gets us to plus
200 should we just do the eight plus
and then we could still take tayden 30
piece that's what I was thinking okay
yeah
eight go eight plus and then throw Tatum
in there I like that
there we go we're working together now
now we are we're connecting dots
381 and we need to get to plus 400 for
the promo
we have one leg left
one leg left
oh you threw oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I
didn't know if we did there
okay so we threw the Jason Tatum leg in
there
okay
we got some more leg left yeah so we got
we got Al Horford over one and a half
threes made Julius Randle eight plus
rebounds Jason Tatum over 30 and a half
points and Spencer dinwiddy 15 plus
points hey should we go get another
minus one thousand
I don't know
see live we get into this every show we
get into this every show Ryan comes in
here and pushes his agenda he pushes
this he's trying to get rich now ask him
how many parlays have he actually won
and got rich since we've been doing this
show
I'm gonna set the line at
three and I'm gonna say under
that's a pretty high line Liv I mean if
if I got rich if I got rich more than
three times I don't think I'd still be
on this show
I'd be on a beach somewhere on an island
I I don't know I I guess we'll set the
line at one and go under yeah I mean
you'd still be correct yeah she was I
was just gonna say you were correct
either way like either way you put it
camera be under is all I'm hearing yeah
there's not even a push there it's under
yeah or the other but listen though Lyft
he comes in here he pushes this agenda
to go to get the highest odds to just go
and get the highest odds we you know me
Sam Michael Bowen some of the guys
that's been here for a while that's been
you know interacting with the audience
that's you know been uh I would say uh
this this just in in engagements with
the audience we know how the audience
sometimes is uh we like to win we like
this lit simply put balls in buckets and
see them go through thank you will thank
you thank you I know how it goes around
here all right you gotta get on board
that's but that's their that's their
prerogative I know what the chat wants
to do the chat wants plus 1200 parlays
and wants to get rich every time I'm
just trying to I'm just trying to be one
of them
see he's the man of the people yes
I don't know why I'm entertaining it I
don't know what happened
that's a losing battle for you
mine is a thousand
and go from there can I can I break up
an idea to you guys just because like I
feel like we're we're ignoring the fact
that we have Luka doncic available to us
and he's not anywhere in this parlay I
was wondering why we weren't talking
about the other game more there's a
whole other game we can look at well
it's because head on over there and see
what's going on right it's Ryan's agenda
live yeah the NBA is the Celtics League
live it's all about the Celtics Okay but
well we're gonna make it let's let's
move on I think we've you know we've
addressed it we we showed them some love
sure maybe we go back we take Celtics
money line make it six legs who knows
but yeah uh all right he's not letting
it rest no there he is
uh all right we need we do need a take
though from the chat about Luca so we
can kind of start to do this do we want
to take points I guess is my my question
off off the rip because we have Spencer
did when he points
somebody says Luca underpoints oh no
and no what about um
maybe like a CP3 assists or something oh
I like that
so you're gonna be dishing tonight
it's at nine and a half
is that nine or nine Ryan
nine nine and a half
that's a nine
where's my eyes deceiving me
uh that's a nine
oh okay
I I'm also almost tempted and I don't
want to to ruin the best bet segment but
I kind of feel like Liv's best bet would
work as a good last leg here
wow Ryan I know I know I mean I I like
what you're doing I love what you're
doing you're trying to connect dots and
that's what we love to do here
um they don't call me producer Ryan
so let's I mean let's do it live the
floor is yours we heard what you think
uh live let's just get right to it the
floor is yours what is your best bet and
we're going to put that into the parlay
and have that riding as the final and
last leg so live take it away
the pressure is on
um I really like Michael Bridges tonight
to hit his over on points the line's at
16 and a half uh he's not only hit this
in the last five but we're seeing a
significant increase in his offensive
role since Booker has been out I like
him to do the same thing tonight not to
mention the Mavs in the last 15 are
allowing around 25 points per game to
opposing shooting guards so I like him
to have a big night I think 16 and a
half is relatively low for what we've
seen from him lately so I'm rocking with
bridges over 16 and a half points
no I like that I like how he's been
bawling too with uh no uh
no Booker no Booker are you out there
Michael Bridges has been that guy from
them so we're rocking we are riding
Michael bridge is over 16 and a half
points Ryan
you see what it does Parlay you see what
it does this parlay well hold on I'll
read it I'll read it off but we do have
some things to talk about now so we have
Al Horford over one and a half made
threes Julius Randle eight plus rebounds
Jason Tatum over 30 and a half points
Spencer Dinwiddie 15 plus points and
then the live leg which is Mikhail
bridges over 16 and a half points live
live yes I call it the live leg because
if this is the leg that sells we know
who to blame
I would delete Twitter as my recognition
that's what Ryan unlike you I can take
ownership I'll admit
hey Liv I like how you straight you
should have been fired
hey Ryan also also I want you to take a
glance at the comments take a glance at
the chat you see the love that they're
given live here okay here's the thing
because it's natural this love yes it is
all love for Liv I'll say that but this
snake darian85 comes back in here and
says if this parlay hits Ryan you're out
of a job my guy I already know if this
parlay doesn't hit I'm somehow gonna get
blamed for it even if it is this
Bridge's leg
yeah
it's an easy thing in all seriousness
though in all seriousness no
what about that Al Horford leg well we I
was gonna say we could tease a lot of
things down now because it's plus 756
all we need to do is get it to Plus 400.
yeah can we tease that down to one I
feel way more comfortable with one than
like
two one and a half I think I agree with
that I feel like that's the one leg
that's making me feel unsettled right
now
all right everything else is nice
yeah it just drops it so much you see
him live look at him look at him
okay Ryan it's gonna be okay I don't
know if it is
I mean we said it only needed to be plus
yeah this is Lockheed it's just like can
we possibly tease Tatum down is that
possible as well
like this is just I was hoping for more
wiggle room I was hoping to be able to
tease down Al worford and Jason Tatum
okay well I do think the eight plus
rebounds feels a little disrespectful I
think he's gonna get more than that
I think you could go up with Randall's
rebounds and then go down with Tatum's
points okay Liv yeah
yeah I feel I feel I feel like eight
plus is like that shouldn't be a problem
for him what's his line at his line is
higher than that 11.
so we could do 10 plus if we wanted to
yeah I I just have my nightmare leaving
this show every week live is that we
take 10 plus and it ends on nine when we
had eight in our hands
you know what I mean when we had it just
like Ryan why are we thinking like that
right bad vibes that's terrible Vibes
out of here why are we even thinking
like me
all right I'm gonna need you to just
like dial it back a little this one
just to make you feel good Ryan I mean
you want to be a man of the people
El Bay is in the comments saying Randall
10 rebound so like
usually mans of the people they respect
people's decisions and they they voucher
right you know what I'm saying that's
right so
don't talk about it be about it Ryan
yeah no I've been quiet these just these
past like few seconds just so when I
clip this out it's an easy cut for me
and then when I tweeted at you guys we
know who's we know who's responsible for
this that's all right fine the people
the people
that's that's what we do do you guys
think it would work if we tease Tatum
down to 25.
oh what are the odds I think the part
yeah no it's be 319 we'd have to do 30.
all right
this is tough
okay Ryan I
you're acting like you're gonna need a
therapy appointment after this are you
gonna be okay if we lose live we haven't
won in such a long time and next week
I'm gonna show up here I'm gonna get
blamed for this losing and it's a
darion's gonna be darian85 is going to
be calling for my job
if it here's the thing you can't keep
doing the same thing and expect a
different result it keeps losing so
we're gonna go for it we're gonna have
Good Vibes we're gonna listen to the
chat and we're gonna win tonight but are
we doing anything different I don't know
if we are
yeah that me not panicky that's never
gonna stop that that'll always be her uh
yeah that that's just what it is but I
like this I think this looks nice the
chat is screaming for Malcolm Brogden
points uh to be specific B Thompson
1992. B Thompson I don't know what you
want from us like what what here do you
not like that
right what are we replacing like what's
yeah yeah
right Kevin Kevin 1981 is also saying
Brogden over on threes but
that's reasonable and they get scary
yeah they definitely do get scared do we
feel better well no because I feel like
Al Horford all used to do is hit one
three
that's it yeah sometimes it says y'all
not listening to the chat Barbie
Thompson if we're not listening to the
chat what what are we not listening to
be specific
bad
random guy LOL what a what a username
random guy LOL says I'm with bro y'all
tweaking what exactly I I first of all
I'm tweaking I'm tweaking oh oh you're
bro yeah I'm bro yeah I'm bro yeah
actually never mind clarify yeah that
was a that was a comment about me never
mind uh so be time to B Thompson said
take Al Horford threes away and add
Brogden points
Brogden over 14 and a half
what is this point total it's probably
like 14 and a half if I had to guess
and it's 14 and a half how about that
that was a great guess that was a great
guess I'll pretend like I I already knew
what it was guys I'm sorry I got I have
to own up to that I had to I knew that I
just want to kill your thunder I knew
you looked yeah I know I know well I
don't hate that do we hate that we're
getting mixed Vibes though like because
now lorienga is in the chat saying fade
Brogden shot by kill said Brockton
hasn't played in two days
oh I don't like backing someone that's
not been playing that's true Risky
Business and uh just to be clear the
only way I would back this play up if we
were to take Al Horford out would be to
take him 10 plus because Al Horford I
think was minus 8.50 for threes and he
ten plus is minus 600 for Brogden
and I don't know if we wanna I like I
don't know how comfortable you guys feel
about taking Malcolm product who hasn't
played in a bit let's ask the chat
that's that's when we go to the chat so
chat this is what we're this is what
we're uh this is what we're trying to
decide are we going to add Malcolm
Brogdon plus 10 points and take out Al
Orford one made three-pointer
thumbs up if you guys are in favor of it
thumbs down if you guys want to keep it
how it is
uh we're gonna see what they're talking
about we're we are going to see what
they are talking about
I don't know how I feel about Malcolm
brother I'll be honest 10 points though
[Music]
I I would like to call out uh Michael
Bowling For Fighting the Army in the
chat right now who doesn't want Spencer
Dinwiddie in here because apparently
he's hit an 80 rate uh in his last 10
games of the number that we have
so wait what he doesn't want him or he
does no no the chats the chat's yelling
about Spencer Dinwiddie and it just it's
not warranted because
they're they're not gonna hit right
they're mad about the name that it
doesn't say Luca doncic or it doesn't
say you know somebody that they want to
fit all right Chad has an agenda too
Ryan look at the chat that sounds like a
thumbs down they don't want Brogden they
want to keep it out uh Al Horford yeah
so I think I think I don't see a world
where Horford does not bank one three
tonight I agree God's sake prime time
especially in a TNT game come on get
real he's gonna be because you know Al
even if he misses the first four he's
taken four more he doesn't care yes one
is bound to go in come on this is Al
we're talking about Prime Time TNT I
love it we gotta keep it yep and I say
we just added Celtics money line and we
just call it a day okay leave that out
and just relax all right
plus 6 14.
fine
we're we're almost at 500 plus 487. yeah
this we need to win we need to win
pretty bad no we need to win we
definitely need to win Ryan read it
because because I'm I'm putting my foot
down we're rocking with this bro
15 plus points Al Horford one plus
three-pointer made Julius Randle
against my will 10 plus rebounds Jason
Tatum 30 plus points and then the live
leg Mikhail bridges over 16 and a half
points five legs Plus 487.
this one's hitting there it is
goodbye live live get just talk to us a
little bit about our parlay give us some
good vibes uh because you know we
usually don't have you on the show
that's the oddsmakers calling they
they're telling us our parlay is going
to hit so uh Liv how do you feel about
our parlay
I mean you only miss the parlays you
don't take you know you never know which
one's a winner until you place it and
you ride it and you sweat it out Ryan I
need better vibes from you moving
forward I've listened I I would agree
with you but I've lost many apart lays
that I've placed so I can't it's because
you have it's because you have bad vibes
yeah exactly yeah
and he comes in here with an agenda he
comes in here trying to push an agenda
because I've been letting it naturally
flow you know what I'm saying right
Gotta Be Like Water it Gotta Be Like
Water it gotta flow it's got a flow
everything's got to flow you gotta have
Good Vibes I love this parlay I'm
praying the live leg hits because Ryan
won't let me hear the end of it if it
doesn't I already um
perfect that's fine I'm ready I am ready
I've been waiting all night for this
thing to either cash or not cash to hear
from Ryan but no I love the parley I
think it's great I'm ready to sweat it
out
leaves ready to sweat it out I'm ready
to sweat it out Ryan's ready to go have
a therapy session after this but uh
um let's create some bets let's let's
let's see what they're talking about in
the chat
the chat see see let's let's ask lib
some uh let's have lib grade these why
not
uh well joy joyous ran somebody random
guy LOL who I still love the username
I'll read that every time I said uh
Randall a plus rebounds
yeah love Yeah a plus would you say you
like it better than 10 plus
no no I think eight plus is playing it
safe we don't play it safe around here
but eight plus I like it
says Julius Randle three plus threes
is or I would just say probably three
over two and a half threes that's his
line his lines minus 122.
I'm gonna give that one a b
minus
threes are tough especially against a
good defense
okay don't I I don't I just don't I
don't think I would bet a three point
player prop against a solid defense
um like the Celtics but um I'll give it
a B minus I don't hate it just wouldn't
take it all right uh LBA is upset that
we didn't put in Luca I mean I don't I
don't know what to I don't know what to
tell you we found locks otherwise you
know right we did right
um um Speco Bulls minus six against the
Charlotte Hornets
[Music]
I don't know how I feel about that one
I'm kind of indifferent
um
yeah
yeah well I I'll give that one a
I'll give that those I I don't feel like
there's a ton of um
those aren't rely for embedding
experience those are not reliable teams
that I would bet on so I'm gonna go
ahead and just sit those are two teams
that I don't trust when you have two
teams you don't trust going head-to-head
anything can happen so I'm gonna give
that one a c okay yeah all right game
for me yes Liv we got one more for you
one more we're gonna get a better
because there's money to be made uh this
is for the app team we have a squad ride
today
um our friend darian85 I believe he is
the squad right your friend
rebounds
I like that
I'm gonna give that one uh
A minus
love it Liv gave it an A minus uh she
likes it I love it Ryan
read the parlay one more time before we
get out of here please brother sure uh
good news the odds have jumped to plus
490 on this parlay so that's yeah that's
like three cents extra no maybe we can
see what happens when you have Good
Vibes Ryan geez yeah maybe this maybe
this means we could tease Tatum down to
25 who knows uh but we'll keep it we'll
keep it the way it is uh Al Horford one
plus made three joyous rattle ten plus
rebounds Jason Tatum 30 plus points
Spencer dinwiddy 15 plus points and the
live leg
pause
Macau bridges over 16 and a half points
Liv he does that on purpose because he
wants to blame yes
yes and it's kind of scaring me yeah
it's it's freaky yeah you see what I
have to deal with uh every Thursday it's
Sunday I do uh pray pray for me please
keep me in your prayers everybody in the
chat yes uh hey but it's time to go win
some money it's time to go win some
money you guys see the parlay at the
bottom of your screen make sure you
screen uh screenshot it screen recorder
do whatever you need to do go place it
in ride with us because we will all be
sweating it together uh but my name is
Greg Ivory Let's Get on Up out of here
my name is Greg Arby next to me is the
lovely live boots and next to her is the
man
we like to call producer Ryan I thought
you're gonna save the people I thought
you were going to say of the people nah
you didn't earn that yet bro
when this cashes when this cash is I
will that's right there you go hey but
we are out of here
peace
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]